[Musique]
si la loi avait su qu'un jour elle
deviendrait patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco serait elle aujourd'hui moins
sauvage - imprévisible
sans doute non pendant des siècles et
des siècles des vikings les autres
marines et se sont glissées dans son lit
pour y faire du trafic et autres
commerces en tous genres du sel du vin
du bois et tant de choses ces
différentes sur des centaines de
kilomètres elle était incontournable axe
principal reliant l'ouest à l'est mais
c'est à la fin du 19e siècle que la
bruyante machine à vapeur crachant de la
fumée qui censure des lignes en fer aura
raison de son agitation
c'est ainsi que la pâte elle rit disparu
avec ses légendes et ses histoires
incroyables de la vie des gens du fleuve
début de matinée en amont de tours plus
d'un siècle après que les derniers
mariniers et plier les voiles clément et
le capitaine de l'un de ces bateaux à
fond plat du temps d'avant gabart
challans fut trop où les autres tous
cabanes et ont repris du service par la
passion grandissante de ces nouveaux
navigateurs des irp ya ceux qui savaient
pas qu'ils aient un aller-retour à bord
de futurs éducateurs nature
environnement parti en touristes d'un
jour
curieux quand lieu de découvrir du
dernier confluence sauvage d'europe
il semblerait que cette batellerie de la
vallée de la loire connaissent comme une
renaissance presque inattendu et
pourtant le dernier naufrage fut des
plus sombres
au début le chemin de fer coûte cher
mais inévitablement c'est tellement
pratique traitement régulier la loire un
problème c'est que la navigation
saisonnière on ne peut naviguer sur la
loire on va éviter que 3,4 par an on
était le niveau est trop bas et en plus
n'aviez donc le chemin de fer c'est
toujours disponible donc ça va diminuer
en permanence et on va essayer de
s'adapter à la situation
donc on va essayer vers 1850 on va
essayer de réaménager la loire en
faisant lit mineur en essayant de voir
en lui qu'il fasse toujours 300 mètres
de large
on va faire des épis on va essayé
d'étrangler le ruisseau de l'été telle
façon que la low creuse matjan finale
l'hiver la loire va monter elle va
submerger ces digues
si le long de la loire on va encore
plein de vestiges de ces scénique
simplement ça marche pas très bien il ya
beaucoup d'accidents il ya des bateaux
qui coule et c'est un problème parce que
la loire et et servait entre autres pour
amener à
saint nazaire par des grosses pièces de
bateaux pour la construction navale dont
comment j'ai retrouvé des témoignages
d'accidentés on me disait des bateaux
qui s'appelait des sapes insee des
bateaux qui ne faisaient qu'un allez on
construisait le bateau on descendait et
une fois qu'on arrivait à nantes on
récupère le bois pour faire autre chose
la grande mystérieuse désormais sort de
son sommeil
avec pour seul objectif assouvir la
curiosité infatigable de ceux qui la
découvrent de ce qu'elle séduit
séductrice depuis si longtemps
le peintre william turner se laissera en
gelée mais aussi au fil des mots des
hommes de lettres
oui tous disparu lorsque j'ai aperçu les
bords de la loire et les collines de la
touraine j'étais tout entière m'a
délicieuse sensation et je m'écris un
mois même auchan aimé des cieux
tranquille pays l'hindustan de la france
où coule un autre ganges que je te vois
avec délice oui ton air est plus parfumé
que celui que je respirais est un
verdure est plus belle que celle que je
foulais honoré de balzac
comme un sentiment de découvrir un
paysage du bout du monde presque
exotique
il est vrai que le problème du chemin de
halage coni cette attirance inexplicable
vers les reflets d'or sombre la loire et
généreuse avec ce qu'ils aiment et qui
voudraient la connaître presque
intimement et de l'avoir à nouveau
revivre tout en la présentant des
projets qui arrivent comme ça un peu
parachuté ou froid il faut développer
attention apprend à connaître la loire
déjà apprendre les nez un peu démago un
jeu bien conscience de dire ça apprend à
l'aimer
on a plein de manières d'aimer les lieux
dès 2000 à la loire effectivement je
pense que ça se sent ça sous-entend de
de la connaître un petit peu de
connaître son son fonctionnement quoi le
rêve de clément ne plus avoir d'obstacle
pour naviguer librement
n'importe quel marinier qui travaille
sur la loire a l'habitude de se faufiler
voilà mais se faufiler dans le sable
c'est possible se faufiler dans les
cailloux dans les fondations de ponlat
c'est vrai qu'ils auraient probablement
des choses à faire des petits
aménagements pas grand-chose qui
servirait aux mariniers qui servirait
aux saumons qui servit rosales à servir
et à pas mal de gens en fait donc c'est
important de remettre en connexion la
mer et la montagne
et c'est la loire qu'il fait si on peut
l'aider à le faire c'est bien
[Musique]
même si la navigation est pour l'instant
saisonnière c'est plus d'une centaine
d'associations qui existent aujourd'hui
pour faire vivre aux visiteurs la magie
de son lit l'association boutavant et sa
flotte
répond elle aussi à une forte demande de
plus en plus pressante alors on innove
on cherche des idées pour offrir une
palette colorée de possibilités voir le
fleuve de l'intérieur c'est un moment
magique une approche de la faune de la
flore totalement unique
comme cet apéro promenade aux produits
du terroir entre chien et loup entre
hérons cendrés et castor
la cosatu
quand le visiteur revient à quai ses
yeux sont encore imprégnés que la vo
démenti des berges nous aussi de l'eau
parfois si claire et de ses bancs de
sable au changement c'est vraiment très
sympa comme comme balade comme ça sur la
loire avec l'apéro est tous vraiment pas
mal très belle s'est très mal à changer
nos paysages à nous un c'est sur la mer
méditerranée la loire une différence
bien peu de magie très très très beau
très vers les maisons en bord de loire
nice magnifique
là on a l'impression d'être complètement
dépaysé d'être loin limite au bord de
mer avec les belles petites plages avec
les baigneurs qu'on parle de relate là
mais ils sont là la loire un vélo la
loire valley quelle prise de conscience
pour mettre en valeur le grand fleuve et
du côté des professionnels du tourisme
c'est qu'il y ait un réel potentiel
d'avenir bien le lieu est unique
le touriste quand il fait une balade
avec boutavant avec la rabouilleuse à
rochecorbon moi en tout cas en bateau
traditionnel de loire c'est une vraie
expérience
c'est une vraie originalité théorie fond
et ne pas vivre ce moment là avec cette
intensité là sur une autre navigation en
rivière idéalement c'est vrai que on
souhaiterait que la loire soit
navigables
et que le le pont wilson puis cette
franchise
il ya également la navigation sur le
cher on voit apparaître également de
nouveaux produits avec des croisiéristes
qui viennent jusqu'aux portes de
villandry avec des gros bateaux
croisières
donc c'est en discussion techniquement
c'est moi mon domaine mais je sais qu'il
ya des difficultés principalement de
réglementation d'aménagement et
certainement de coûts mais oui
idéalement on souhaiterait que ce soit
davantage navigable sur sierra des
troncs sont beaucoup plus importants
jean pierre berton et le président de
boutavent saloir il la connaît lui aussi
il a de grands projets pour elle pour la
faire revivre pas comme avant car le
monde moderne n'a plus besoin d'elle
mais pour le plaisir qu'elle nous offre
sans retenue mais voilà le grand fleuve
a changé et la batellerie traditionnels
ne s'y déplacent plus facilement
seul le petit canotage à tirer pour
l'instant son épingle du jeu
les canoës ont la part belle dans le
développement parce qu'il n'y a pas de
problème particulier de ce seuil a passé
puisqu'on peut soulever un canot elle et
puis l'emmener ailleurs
donc c'est facile ainsi concerne les
plus gros bateaux y compris les bateaux
traditionnels les préconisations sont
qu'ils naviguent par bassin de
navigation
c'est à dire qu'il ya une cartographie
des seuils à l'étiage quasiment
infranchissable pour les bateaux qui
font huit tonnes
même notons pas facile donc les bateaux
actuels généralement font des ronds dans
l'eau quand je dis les ronds dans l'eau
c'est les promenades d'une heure ou de
deux heures qu'on soit sommer pour soi
on reçoit orléans conçoit jour etc
on est très limité et
moi je voudrais un petit peu que ce
schéma directeur soit modifié pour ce
qui n'est pas traitée c'est à dire la
partie saisonnière qui se trouve en fait
l'hiver et le printemps lorsque les eaux
de la loire son sans faute et tant que
les eaux de la loire sont la plupart des
seuils sont effacés et on peut prévoir
des promenades beaucoup plus longue en
particulier à tours on aurait le projet
de développer ce qui apparaît banal une
promenade entre tours et amboise
[Musique]
les quais de loire à tours ont sans
doute oublié il était le coeur de vie de
la ville
aujourd'hui nous invite à la douceur de
vivre
mais il se prépare petit à petit au
changement la loire s'y prêtent
volontiers et les ligériens ou une idée
derrière la tête un fleuve navigue à
toute l'année ou presque
si on reprend un peu ce qu'avait fait
nos ancêtres en terme de navigation
il faut créer les bateaux il faut avoir
les bateaux qui servait autrefois qui
soit à la fois des bateaux ouvert ce
qu'on a déjà ce qu'on voit déjà les
gabarres les to et puis il faut avoir
des bateaux fermé pour qu'on puisse
avoir un usage de cette loi qui soit pas
quelques dizaines à aller de quelques
dizaine de jours par an qui soit un
usage beaucoup plus régulier et qu'on
puisse le je conseille à tout le monde
la loire au mois d'octobre au mois
d'octobre c'est merveilleux c'est de
noir merveilleuse extraordinaire mon
masque année au mois d'octobre ya vingt
jours de pluie souvent en touraine donc
il faut prévoir ça il faut qu'on puisse
naviguer sur cette loi en endormant
bénéficiant mais évidemment on ne la
supprimerons pas donc l'idée c'est
d'avoir des bateaux fermé et de
commencer par ce qu on appelle lune tout
ce qui est des caractéristiques d'un
bateau cabinet ctr allait fermer et on
ne puisse être dedans et qu'on puisse
aller profiter de la loire profiter de
l'intérêt de la faune de la flore ben
même quand il ya un petit crachin ou
même quand il pleut vraiment et pouvoir
se déplacer être à plusieurs à
l'intérieur de moi la poire pour créer
une situation conviviale au sein de la
loire pour soit pas soumise totalement
aux aléas
il y a donc le projet d'un bateau de
plus de 30 m avec 70 places qui pourrait
naviguer par tous les temps mais aux
recrues et grand froid à bateaux qui en
période estivale faute de profondeur
d'eau resteraient à quai pour accueillir
les produits du terroir et de raconter
l'histoire de la marine de loire pour un
voyage au long cours et tout cannes et
il faudrait aussi que les peaux de mont
louis et le vieux pont de pierre de
tours puisse laisser franchir
et aussi incroyable que cela puisse
paraître avec quelques aménagements
cela serait possible c'est le rêve
presque inavoué de certains mais aussi
une réponse à une demande touristique
réel
[Musique]
la loire intarissable de surprise de
magie pour et pour de nombreuses années
nous livrer encore des secrets
écrire une nouvelle page de sa
légendaire histoire